le festival total prend ses quartiers au
théâtre de champ fleuri
un festival jeune public devenu un
rendez vous culturel particulier pour
les petits mais également les grands
puisque le spectacle se découvre en
famille de demander le programme c'est
avec pascal montrouge que le voyage
débute total septième édition
c'est pendant quatre jours en tout cas
pour les tout public
trois spectacles par jour à 14 heures à
16 heures et à 18 heures ce sont des
spectacles différents ces six spectacles
différents
sur les six spectacles différents il ya
une création avec son guide création du
groupe sont avec la compagnie tetra
danse pour un concert de rock électro
bien bien déjanté il ya aussi de la
danse avec la compagnie lionel hoche
killen métropole avec de la vidéo et les
costumes incroyables c'est super beau la
compagnie la ravine rousse pour mamie
obama bill qui mêle ou théâtre cirque
danse c'est d'une grande grande poésie
le carton de l'année dernière avec la
compagnie
no gravity du théâtre avec la compagnie
acta qui nous invite à regarder avec des
yeux d'enfant la tragédie
shakespearienne roméo juliette des
marionnettes des cinq essais à travers
les yeux de la nourrice de juliette que
l'amour impossible est racontée aux
enfants maurice ravel célèbre
compositeur du boléro a aussi composé
pour les petits en s'inspirant des
contes de charles perrault accompagné de
lionel hoche sert un mmo inspiré de la
mer noire nous emmène dans une nature
psychédélique plus sage mais tout aussi
fantasque la compagnie de la rabine
rousse propose quatre genres artistiques
en ans du cirque de la musique de la
danse et du mime l'histoire on suit le
parcours en fait d'un être qui vient au
monde et qui va au devant d'un tas de
situations et de toutes ces expériences
et des mises en situation du personnage
et ses expériences vous tapiez de
modifier le le faire évoluer et au cours
du spectacle des seuils un tas de pas
seulement de costumes de postures donc
tantôt fille tantôt garçons y abete a
fait une programmation espiègle et
propose des courts métrages venus tout
droit de lettonie au cinéma d'animation
indépendant et malicieux un vrai retour
dans l'imaginaire enfantin mais l'écran
peuvent aussi s'y laisser piéger
je vais vous présenter quatre courts
métrages d'animation lettonien
faire marionnettes donc
l'histoire c'est vraiment la nature
l'entr'aide ou les pièges que peuvent
poser entre les humains et les animaux
donc voilà ces quelques petits courts
mais trash à partir de 4 ans et ça dure
45 minutes et c'est avec une création
qu'ils ont plus connu pour sa musique
électro dessiner un public averti que
premier spectacle pour enfants
s'invitent sur la scène du théâtre zinc
est devenu le temps du festival total
z'ont keats c'est d'ailleurs un avant
goût de ce spectacle qui a été offert à
des scolaires et à des enfants en
situation de handicap
musicalement on peut reconnaître
certaines mines de bassam certaines
notes et puis pour le reste c'est ouvert
on est là on regarde comment on jauge un
petit peu l'énergie de la salle
l'ambiance
et puis ensuite juste on se lâche et on
invite les enfants sa passion de la
danse aussi avec l'union gravity
emergency de jérôme fabre et danseurs
qui reviennent à la jeunesse de leur
histoire là où tout a commencé
au total en particulier oui c'est
vraiment important pour nous parce que
c'est là qu'on a commencé aussi le
premier spectacle monsieur montrouge
nous a invités à faire
c'était au total justement on avait
monté quelque chose d'assez
approximative qu'on avait présentée
devant le théâtre en gratuit c'est la
chance qui nous avait donné c'est de là
qu'il a qui nous a proposé ensuite de
rencontrer chez rembrandt et de faire
émerger nsi qui aujourd'hui a tourné
dans toute l'île et donc c'est un
plaisir de pouvoir leur jeu pour toutes
au total cette occasion c'est pour tout
le monde donc il n'y a pas de
discrimination tout le monde veut venir
et il y aura la maille photo show pour
faire des photos dans les courants d'air
et ça va bien être drôle il ya daniel
waro qui nous fait les jeux lontan il ya
la bibliothèque départementale avec qui
on continue donc il sera dans un endroit
bien au frais pour que justement puisse
se reposer entre deux spectacles
la baby disco toujours dans les endroits
dans tera et tout ce petit monde pourra
finir en boîte de nuit ou plutôt dans la
baby disco avis aux parents la piste de
danse est interdite aux personnes de
plus d'un mètre cinquante